Has "The Simpsons" predicted the future once
again? Some fans think the events of a 2006
episode are eerily similar to the real-life
2023 catastrophe of the Titan submersible.
Fans have often noticed that "The
Simpsons" has eerily predicted a
lot of things that have ended up coming
true. For one, Donald Trump's presidency.
"As you know, we've inherited quite a
budget crunch from President Trump."
The show is also thought to have predicted several
different Super Bowl outcomes, smart watches,
Sigfried getting attacked by his own tiger
during a show, the FIFA corruption scandal,
and Donald Trump running for president
again in 2024. The list goes on and on. Now,
fans are saying that the long-running
animated series also predicted the
Titan submersible imploding underwater while
searching for the wreckage of the Titanic.
In the Season 17 episode "Homer's Paternity
Coot," Homer thinks he's found his "real" father,
a guy named Mason Fairbanks, who's voiced
by guest star Michael York. Inexplicably,
the two set out to find underwater treasure in
the wreckage of a ship called the "Piso Mojado"
which is Spanish for "wet floor." Homer,
predictably, gets stuck in the wreckage.
He loses oxygen in the deep ocean and wakes
up in a hospital a few days later — meeting
a very different fate than the five people
aboard the Titan submersible. Yet fans took
to Twitter to claim that, once again, "The
Simpsons" seems to have predicted the future.
On the one hand, "The Simpsons" has been on
the air for so long — since December 1989,
to be specific — that it feels like an
inevitability that the show would end up
predicting some real-life events by coincidence.
And that seems to be the case with all the
instances fans have noticed. That said, it's still
freaking fans out how similar this instance was
to the real-life tragedy. One fan on Twitter
wrote, before the determination was made that
the sub imploded and experts were thinking the
people inside were running out of breathable air:
"The Simpsons really predicted the
titanic submarine situation .. and
that they would completely run out of
oxygen [...] this is actually scary."
Another was clearly unsettled,
making the simple proclamation:
"we live in a simulation."
But it's worth pointing out how different the
real-life incident was from the story of "The
Simpsons" episode. The Titan submersible
embarked on its journey to explore the
wreckage of the Titanic on Sunday, June
18, 2023, with five passengers aboard:
OceanGate founder Stockton Rush, Hamish
Harding, Paul-Henri Nargeolet, Shahzada Dawood,
and Dawood's 19-year-old son Suleman. The
problems started pretty much immediately,
with the craft's communications failing within
the first two hours of the voyage. On Thursday,
June 22, officials determined that the five
passengers had perished, likely in an implosion.
In a press conference after an extensive
search, Rear Admiral John Mauger,
who serves as the commander of the First Coast
Guard District, delivered the sobering news.
"The debris is consistent with a
catastrophic implosion of the vessel."
The experts believe that the implosion happened
shortly after communications were lost,
especially after they found debris from the
Titan itself near the Titanic's wreckage.
Despite the differences, another Twitter
user seemed to feel personally targeted
by the similarities to the "Simpsons" episode,
writing before the Thursday press conference,
"every new detail of this story feels like it
was engineered to drive me specifically insane.
mike reiss, previous visitor to titanic wreckage
and author of simpsons episodes 'moaning lisa'
'stark raving dad' and 'the way we was', says
on chance for survivors he's 'not optimistic.'"
That's right: Mike Reiss, former showrunner
and writer on "The Simpsons," has a personal
connection to the expedition. On June 19,
he told "BBC Breakfast" that he wasn't
hopeful about the fate of the passengers
on board, and he knew better than most.
"I don't know how anyone's going to be able
to access it, much less bring it back up."
Reiss has actually gone on three separate
expeditions with OceanGate, the company that made
the Titan, and he knows that their safety measures
weren't always great from personal experience. He
even said that, during all of his dives, the
crafts lost communication with ground control.
"I got on the sub and at the
back of my mind was 'well,
I may never get off this thing,' that's
always with you. [...] You have to just
remember the early days of the space
program or the early days of aviation,
where you just make a lot of mistakes on
the way to figuring out what you're doing."
There's still a lot of unanswered questions
where the Titan is concerned — and many of
those answers might never come. In any case, "The
Simpsons" has the weirdest possible connection
to this entire situation, and its prediction
streak continues, at least in the eyes of fans.